[music]
avoid scarcity
on the flower bed the floors covered it
[music]
looked back
just a table
on Putin I write in the smoke links thick
thick with such Zalin oil just such a
song what black smoke I write
and the soundboard block bulging one groovy
I was trembling all over,
it was terribly falling in. In general, it was the beginning of the
ninth, I woke up, I thought now I’ll take a
shower, I’ll shave at that time, it will thunder,
I didn’t understand what it was there when I
opened my eyes, I saw the door to my right vomited
and there the collapse was the first thing that I had in
my head This is what  with my son, I shout
Sanya, how are you there, are you alive
for the second time, he answered even that
calmed me down, then I started to get out
Well, I have no words to express how
to call it
As they say, like war is war
Anything can happen, but this is not war This is a
crime  in front of humanity I
just don’t want to
express what I think in plain
text But this is a crime that
is being committed now I
don’t even want to call him a
man what  -something There's just blasphemy
I came in a bag
I came I fell asleep
six wave everything came back from the duna and
all of them their luck on us killed their children